turner NCAA basketball analyst Brendan
Haywood joining the Rich Eisen show
what's up Brendan how are we doing today
my man I'm glad you can come on to help
me figure out what the heck is going to
happen on Saturday I've said look it's
two matches okay two matchups it's the
the the main event which is the late
game Villanova in Kansas but the under
car Michigan versus Loyola Chicago and
when you look at Michigan one of the
hottest teams right now in all of
college basketball 13 games in a row
that they've won but Brendan I was at
that game the Elite Eight matchup you
know versus Florida State they didn't
shoot the ball fairly well what will
they need to do in this game in the
final four if they're not shooting the
ball well how will Michigan win this
game well first of all you're a football
guy you're very suited that all you have
to shoot the ball well if you're
Michigan um three of their four games of
their last four games and tournaments
they didn't shoot the ball or they had
that one hot shooting game to Texas A&M
but besides that they haven't been
accused of all great the tournament's
they're gonna have to do that again so
Ellis offenses one misuse calling cards
and then also decently they're going to
have to make Loyola uncomfortable too
many teams Loyola come up here one there
since there's extra matters they take
time off the clock they're patient they
read the match up correctly they find a
mismatch and because we all is a team
full of a bunch of guards an average
between about 13 to 7 points you can't
home in on one guy so when I saw all the
struggle with win teams like Nevada they
picked up the pressure because they were
losing the beginning of the game make
for Yola uncomfortable Michigan has they
need to use that from the very start of
the game you know the one thing is leyla
Chicago is shot with 60% from the field
throughout the tournament and you
mentioned how do you kind of disrupt
their flow of what's going on I look the
comparison I make is this Brendan you're
climbing Mount Everest right Loyola
Chicago is climbing they're climbing
they see the top of the mountain but all
of a sudden before they get there they
look back or they look down and like oh
I don't
we're I didn't know we were this high up
is is there some sort of that
possibly in this Final Four matchup for
them that they realize hey we're not
even supposed are we good enough to even
be in this Final Four I think they will
play Cinderella that barely barely won a
couple of games this thing's got one of
the longest winning streak in all of
college basketball
they beat Florida this year at Florida
State defense by n they'll both go 12
points longer average this is also a top
five reasons a team in the nation they
think that all along this is basically
false yet simply exactly like what I've
seen them it's controlled simple they're
very patient
Bryn I don't know if you want to bring
out the UVA comparison because UVA ever
again we're joined now by Turner Sports
and CBS sports analyst Brendan Haywood
Brendan will be part of the final four
studio coverage this weekend with
pregame halftime post game analysis and
all the games available exclusively on
TBS and the corresponding team cast
presentation for the Final Four in
national championship will be available
on TNT and truTV not Brennan if Loyola
Chicago wins this thing okay
would you be surprised
we're gonna win at all if you if they
win at all if they win the national
title they take down Michigan they beat
either Villanova or Arkansas if they win
the national title would you be
surprised yeah Kansas or Villanova and
I'm a big girl know I'm a big Villanova
supporter biggest winning a championship
yeah nothing short of crazy but like I
said there is a main event and the main
event is that night cap the game 849
p.m. Eastern time number one Villanova
vs. number one Kansas two different
paths you've seen Kansas the emotional
win over Duke and over time you know
Grayson Allen makes that shot it could
be Duke but now it's Kansas they're in
that matchup and then Villanova kind of
rolling through the turn how do you see
this one playing a couple more questions
for you here Brendan before I let you go
obvious there's a couple guys that
entered the NBA Draft
before put their name in the head
clear we know Marvin Bagley of Duke he's
going to enter the draft we saw that one
coming in bridges over at Michigan State
as well when you look at the NBA Draft
coming up in June the two guys are the
consensus we think are going to be a one
and two are Marvin Bagley and DeAndre
Aiden of Arizona if you had the chance
to pick either one at number one who is
your guy right now in the yeah a lot of
young guys don't get the rotation so
it's not an indictment of what he will
be into pro but the honoree gets it now
he makes his mark on defense and offense
right now I would think them over Marvin
badly but Marvin is really talented but
he's gonna have to pick it up on the end
of the court hey bring the last one
before I let you go today's opening day
of Major League Baseball I know you were
born in New York but you went to high
school in North Carolina who is your
baseball legions goes to what is your
baseball legions who is your team
fashion city I don't know anything about
people
god I think you go to that but that's
alright Britain yeah we appreciate the
time I guess everybody's go-to is odd to
be a Yankee fan see that's where the
world's coming appreciate the time it
would take no check you out this weekend
on all the coverage with CBS
that's Bryn and a wood turner NCAA
analyst like you catch Brennan he'll be
part of the final four studio coverage
this weekend pregame halftime post game
analysis all of the games available
exclusively on TBS and the team cast
what I'm a big fan of the team cast
presentations for the final four
National Championship will be available
on TNT and the one time of year always
find out what channel is truTV the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience